I will not say when we are going to attack,
but attack we will.
They will be met with fire and fury like the
world has never seen.
It's almost nine months into Donald Trump's
presidency
and I've got a question specifically for the
old "Libertarians for Trump" crowd:
How much more winning can you take?
I urge all of my fellow Americans to stand
up and vote for Donald Trump.
There was a small but vocal band of limited-government
folks
who supported the billionaire real estate
mogul
on the grounds that he couldn't possibly be
as bad as Hillary Clinton
or even most of the other Republican candidates,
especially when it came to foreign policy.
I personally have had to put aside my Libertarian
beliefs to support Trump....
I think that I won the debate, is because
of his inability or refusal
to rank Hillary and Donald...
Leading the pack was economist Walter Block,
who beat me in a competitive debate in New
York City right before the election,
on whether or not Libertarians should support
Trump.
Block’s argument was that “the perfect
is the enemy of the good”
and “the Donald is the most congruent with
[the libertarian] perspective”
especially on foreign policy.
But Trump has turned out to be anything but
a non-interventionist.
He promised to bring fire and fury to North
Korea,
“the likes of which, in this world has never
seen before.”
He bombed Syria on the same humanitarian grounds
he explicitly denounced during his campaign.
He escalated war efforts in Yemen and Iraq,
and more recently, announced plans to "win"
in Afghanistan.
His secretary of state declared that
the US might not walk away with a "battlefield"
victory in the graveyard of empires,
but neither would the Taliban.
That’s not inspirational, it’s stupid.
Apart from his foreign policy follies,
this anti-free-trader and nativist
has turned out to be even less libertarian
than advertised during the campaign.
They're rapists and some, I assume are good people.
White lives matter!
He’s continued giving mealy-mouthed support
to white supremacists
and pardoned Joe Arpaio, "America's toughest
sheriff,"
who was found in contempt of court after he
continued to illegally racially profile
and detain Latino suspects.
Nobody is higher than me.
And Trump's attorney general Jeff Sessions
is walking back a decade of incremental progress
on criminal justice reform.
Trump's deregulatory push is all to the good,
but it’s overwhelmed by his other
policies.
And there's also no question
that at this point Trump is doing virtually
everything he can do to alienate libertarians
who believe in shrinking the size, scope,
and spending of government.
Donald, what do you think of Libertarianism?
I like it, a lot of, a lot of good things.
I don't wanna talk to you now, but a lot of
good things, a lot of good points.
The excuse that Hillary Clinton would have
been worse is getting older than Bernie Sanders.
The perfect is the enemy of the good
but what the president has shown us so far
just isn’t good enough.